>> SECRETARY BLINKEN, WELCOME
TO THE PROGRAM.
>> CHRISTIANE, GREAT TO BE WITH
YOU.
>> I JUST WANTED TO ASK YOU.
YOU HAVE JUST BEEN MEETING WITH
YOUR UKRAINIAN COUNTERPART.
HE TOLD YOU ALL THAT THEY NEED
WEAPONS FASTER, FASTER, AND
FASTER.
IS IT TRUE THAT NATO IS RUNNING
OUT OF AMMUNITION?
FOR INSTANCE, ARTILLERY.
UKRAINIANS ARE USING IT.
>> FROM DAY ONE, IN FACT, EVEN
BEFORE DAY ONE, EVEN BEFORE THE
RUSSIAN AGGRESSION STARTED,
THIS IS WHAT WE SAW COMING.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
UKRAINIANS TO GET THEM WHAT
THEY NEED TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
AND PUSH BACK THE RUSSIAN
AGGRESSION.
EVERY STEP ALONG THE WAY, IN
CONSULTATION WITH THEM, IN
CONSULTATION WITH ALLIES AND
PARTNERS, WE HAVE ADJUSTED AS
THE NATURE OF THE AGGRESSION IT
IS SHIFTING.
THEY ARE GETTING IT INTO THEIR
HANDS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY
NEEDED TO DEAL WITH PUTIN'S WAR.
THAT PROCESS CONTINUES.
WE ARE NOW VERY FOCUSED ON AIR
DEFENSE SYSTEMS AND NOT JUST US,
BUT MANY OTHER COUNTRIES.
WE ARE WORKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE UKRAINIANS GET THOSE
SYSTEMS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
BUT ALSO AS EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE.
MAKING SURE THEY ARE TRAINED ON
THE, MAKING SURE THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MAINTAIN THEM.
ALL OF THAT HAS TO COME
TOGETHER.
IT IS.
WE HAVE A VERY DELIBERATE
PROCESS ESTABLISHED BY THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE, LLOYD
AUSTIN.
THAT IS IN RAMSTEIN, GERMANY.
THEY MEET REGULARLY TO MAKE
SURE THE UKRAINIANS GET WHAT
THEY NEED AND WHEN THEY NEED
IT.
>> THIS IS FROM THE PENTAGON
AND YOU AT NATO IT IS REGARDING
THE AMERICAN PATRIOTS.
LIKE YOU SAID, THEY NEED THE
ANTI OR DEFENSE SYSTEMS.
YOU MUST THINK THAT THEY NEED
MORE IRVINE.
TO ME A PUTIN'S RATCHETING UP
HIS MISSILE ATTACK, HIS MISSILE
WARS AGAINST THESE CITIES.
WILL THE UNITED STATES GIVE
PATRIOT SYSTEMS?
IF NOT, WHY NOT?
>> HOW DO NOT WANT TO SPEAK TO
THE SPECIFIC SYSTEMS.
THE PENTAGON IS FOCUSED ON.
AT WHAT WE DO, WE MAKE SURE
THAT IT ANY GIVEN TIME THEY
HAVE THE MOST EFFECTIVE SYSTEMS
POSSIBLE TO DEAL WITH THE
THREAT THEY ARE FACING.
WE JUST RECENTLY PROVIDED THEM
WITH A VERY EFFECTIVE SYSTEM
THAT THEY ARE USING VERY
EFFECTIVELY.
BEFORE THAT, WE HAD THE HIGH
MARKS.
THEY USED TO GET THAT IN GREAT
EFFECT.
BOTH IF THEY HAD SOUTHERN AND
EASTERN UKRAINE.
VIRTUALLY EVERY SINGLE DAY, THE
PENTAGON IS LOOKING AT THIS.
THEY ARE LISTENING TO THE
UKRAINIANS.
THEY ARE CONSULTING THE ALLIES
AND PARTNERS.
IF WE DON'T HAVE SOMETHING, WE
ARE TRYING TO FIND ELSEWHERE.
THAT IS PART OF THIS ENTIRE
COORDINATION PROCESS.
>> WHAT GOES THROUGH YOUR MIND
WHEN YOU SEE HOW PRESIDENT
PUTIN AND THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
IS BASICALLY SHIFTING FROM YOUR
FAILURES ON THE BATTLEFIELD,
LOSSES OF TERRITORY TO THIS
RELENTLESS ATTACK ON THE CITIES.
ARE YOU SATISFIED THAT AS MUCH
HERE IS SOPHISTICATED?
MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEMS ARE
GETTING TO THEM IN TIME.
>> WHAT WE ARE SEEING, LET'S
PUT IT IN ONE WORD.
THAT IS BARBARIC.
THIS IS PRECISELY BECAUSE PUTIN
IS NOT ABLE TO SUCCEED ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
HE IS TAKING THE WAR TO UKRAINE
CIVILIANS.
HE IS DOING IT IN A VERY
DELIBERATE WAY.
HE IS GOING AFTER THE ENTIRE
ENERGY AND ELECTRIC
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HE WANTS TO TURN OFF THE
LIGHTS.
HE WANTS TO TURN OFF THE WATER,
TURN OFF THE HEAT.
THAT COMES AT A TIME WHEN
UKRAINE IS HEADED INTO THE
WINTER.
THE HEAD OF NATO, JAN
STOLTENBERG, HE TALKED ABOUT
WEAPONIZING WINTER.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN IS DOING.
THIS IS ALL SOUL, WAIANAE ARE
WE SEEING TO MAKE SURE THAT
UKRAINE HAS THE SYSTEMS IT
NEEDS TO DEFEND ITSELF, BUT WE
ARE ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
AND AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO
HELP THEM REPAIR AND REPLACE
EVERYTHING THAT HAS BEEN
DESTROYED BY THE RUSSIAN
ONSLAUGHT.
JUST AS WE PUT THIS PROCESS
TOGETHER SOME MONTHS AGO IN
RAMSTEIN, JEREMY, WE WANT TO
GET THEM THE DEFENSIVE WEAPON
SYSTEMS THEY NEED.
SO TOO WE ARE DOING THAT WITH
ENERGY, WITH EQUIPMENT, WITH
TRANSFORMERS.
WITH GENERATORS.
WITH A SPARE PARTS.
.
WE ADMIT HERE IN BUCHAREST.
THIS IS NOT JUST WITH NATO
ALLIES.
BUT WITH THE G7 COUNTRIES AND
SOME OTHER COUNTRIES.
WE PUT IN PLACE A VERY
COORDINATED PROCESS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE GETTING
UKRAINE WHAT IT NEEDS TO GET
THROUGH THE WINTER.
.
WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT MAN,
WOMEN, AND CHILDREN ARE NOT
LITERALLY FREEZING TO DEATH.
THIS IS MY FRIEND AND
COUNTERPART.
HE JUST CAME FROM KYIV AND
DESCRIBED ALL OF THE MINISTERS
HERE.
THIS IS WHAT LIFE IS LIKE UNDER
THE RUSSIAN ONSLAUGHT.
BY THE WAY, THIS IS NOT NORMAL.
THIS IS THE BRUTALIZATION OF A
COUNTRY.
IT IS DIRECTLY ATTACKING
EVERYTHING THAT ITS CIVILIANS
ADDITIONS NEED TO SIMPLY
SURVIVE.
OF THE WORLD UNDERSTANDS IT AND
SEES IT THAT WAY.
WE ARE PLEASED WITH THIS.
WE ARE ACTING IN A WAY TO GET
UKRAINE EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY
CAN TO GET THROUGH THAT WINTER.
>> ONE LAST QUESTION ON THIS
ISSUE OF WEAPONRY AND WHAT THEY
NEED.
THE NEW YORK TIMES REPORTING
THAT U.S. NATO ARE CONSIDERING
INVESTING IN SLOVAKIA, THE
CZECH REPUBLIC, BULGARIA.
THESE ARE FACTORIES THAT HAVE
MADE SOVIET ERA AMMUNITION FOR
ARTILLERY.
APPARENTLY UKRAINE IS MOSTLY
USING IT.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT THAT.
THEY GET WHAT THEY NEED, WHAT
CAN BE MOST EFFECTIVE FOR THEM.
SOME OF THAT GOES TO THE
SOVIET-ERA SYSTEM THEY HAD IN
THEIR INVENTORY FOR DECADES.
FOR EXAMPLE, THEY MADE SURE
THAT THE AMMUNITION WAS THERE
FOR THOSE SYSTEMS.
IN SOME CASES, THEY MIGHT
PRODUCE THINGS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN PRODUCED FOR SOMETIME.
WE ARE LOOKING ACROSS THE BOARD
AT ALL OF THAT.
EVEN AS WE ARE WORKING TO GET
UKRAINE WHAT THEY NEEDED MOST
URGENTLY, WE ARE ALSO WORKING
TO MAKE SURE THAT OVER THE
MEDIUM AND LONG TERM THAT WE
ARE HELPING THEM TO BUILD UP
THEIR CAPACITY TO DETER AND
DEFEND AGAINST FUTURE
AGGRESSION.
WHEN THIS WAR COMES TO AN END
ONE, OF THE THINGS THAT IS
GONNA BE SO CRITICAL OF MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO ENSURE
THAT IT IS NOW REPEAT ITSELF.
RUSSIA DOES NOT RENEW ITS
AGGRESSION AGAINST UKRAINE.
PART OF THAT IS MAKING SURE
THAT THE UKRAINE HAS, OVER THE
LONG TERM, THE ABILITY TO DETER
AGGRESSIONS AND DEFEND ITSELF
IF AGGRESSION COMES.
.
>> CAN I MOVE ON TO A NON-?
ON THE ONE HAND, YOU AND OTHERS
ACCUSE THEM OF SUPPLYING
RUSSIANS WITH MUCH WEAPONRY.
MERCEDES KAMIKAZE DRONES.
HUGE AMOUNT OF DAMAGE AND
DEATH.
I ALSO WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
YOUR REACTION TO THE COURT.
IRAN HAS TOLD YOU THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY THAT IT
PLANS TO UPGRADE AND INCREASE
IT'S PRODUCTION.
IT IS NEAR BOMB CAPACITY.
MOVE NOT TO AN AREA THAT IS
DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO ATTACK.
YOU CAN INCREASE NUCLEAR FUEL
PRODUCTION IN OTHER PLACES.
THE UNITED STATES AND ISRAEL
ARE ACCUSED OF SABOTAGE.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
HAVE THEY TOLD YOU THAT?
>> CHRISTIANE, I THINK THAT THE
WORLD IS FOCUSED ON WHAT IS
HAPPENING ON THE STREETS IN
IRAN THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
[INTERPRETER]
>> THOSE ARE INCREDIBLY BRAVE
YOUNG PEOPLE.
THEY ARE MOSTLY WOMEN.
THEY ARE STANDING UP, SPEAKING
OUT FOR THEIR MOST BASIC
RIGHTS.
THAT IS THE CASE SINCE THE
KILLING OF AUSTIN AMINI SOME
MONTHS AGO.
THAT IS WHERE THE WORLD'S FOCUS
IS.
THAT IS WHERE OUR FOCUS IS.
WE HAVE TAKEN STEPS TO SANCTION
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN RESPONSIBLE.
WE HAVE WORKED AS WELL TO MAKE
SURE THAT IRANIANS, TO THE BEST
OF OUR ABILITY, THEY HAVE THE
COMMUNICATIONS TECHNOLOGY THEY
NEED TO CONTINUE COMMUNICATING
WITH ONE ANOTHER.
THEY ARE STAYING CONNECTED TO
THE OUTSIDE WORLD.
WE HAVE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE
THAT THE BEST WAY TO DEAL WITH
IRAN'S NUCLEAR THREAT IS
THROUGH DIPLOMACY.
YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVEN'T AGREED
WITH THE JCPOA A.
WE PUT IRAN'S NUCLEAR PROTEST
IN THE BOX.
THIS DECISION WAS MADE A POINT
OF THAT AGREEMENT.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN VIRTUALLY
EVER SINCE IT IS IRAN BUILDING
BACK THE PROGRAM.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR WITH
THEM NOT JUST THE UNITED STATES
THESE ARE OTHERS.
THAT INCLUDES EUROPEAN PARTNERS
THEY SHOULD NOT TAKE ADDITIONAL
STEPS TO INCREASE THEIR NUCLEAR
CAPACITY.
THAT INCLUDES BY AND WATCHING
THIS TO HIGHER LEVELS.
--
>> NEXT TRIP IS TO CHINA.
I BELIEVE IT WILL BE YOUR FIRST
TRIP AS THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS.
BEEN --
HE WANTED TO LOWER THE
TEMPERATURE MAKE SURE WE DON'T
ENTER A NEW COLD WAR I WANT TO
ASK YOU THIS.
THIS IS WHAT CHINA DID ALONG
WITH SAUDI ARABIA TO BLOCK ANY
MEANINGFUL --
THIS IS COP27.
THIS IS HOW THE INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONS --
IF THEY'RE NOT GONNA PLAY BALL
ON CLIMATE, IF THEY ARE ANGRY
ABOUT TAIWAN, PARTICULARLY WITH
NANCY PELOSI'S VISIT, WHAT IS
IT THAT YOU HAVE TO TALK ABOUT?
CAN YOU HOPE TO VISIT IN CHINA?
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
PRESIDENT XI HAD AN IMPORTANT
MEETING.
ONE THAT WAS PRODUCTIVE IN THE
SENSE THAT IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE COMMUNICATE CLEARLY.
WE DISCUSS OUR INTERESTS, OUR
INTENTIONS, OUR POLICIES.
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN COOPERATION
WITH CHINA.
WE ARE NOT AT LEAST
UNDERSTANDING WHAT OTHERS ARE
TRYING TO DO.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
TO GUARD AGAINST.
THAT IS NECESSARY PARTICULARLY
IF PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS THAT
THE --
IT DOES NOT LEAD US IN THE
CONFLICT NO ONE HAS AN INTEREST
IN THAT.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, THE TRUTH
THAT I WILL TAKE EARLY NEXT
YEARS ABOUT CONTINUING THAT
COMMUNICATION.
THEY ARE OPEN EVEN WE DISAGREE.
ONLY DISAGREE PROFOUNDLY.